the Joe Rogan experience and that's I
think that's the special bond hunters
have with their food their meat it's
behind me specifically you know that
that the guy who is aberrant yes got
some Mormons laurent yeah boring whole
yeah it's like what are you talking
about well he's a fool yes literally
carving into a steak while we're saying
that right so hunters have that
connection and I saw this video today
this is what drives me crazy and I don't
I don't want to go back rehash
everything we've ever talked about but I
saw this video today who had it up
anyway these vegans were set up in front
of this I guess we get hamburgers oh
that big guy on the line yeah yeah so
when do hunters ever like get
confrontational and violent with people
who don't want to eat meat right when
does that happen well they think somehow
another by blocking this burger stand
that they're changing the world they're
just trying to be activists you know
they're trying to get a message out and
most of them were quit they're gonna
quit veganism they're gonna start eating
meat again because their health yes
that's the truth it's some ridiculous
number google this what number I think
they said the number of vegans and
vegetarians that eat meat when they're
drunk is something outrageous but a
close to 90 percent yeah but how many
how many vegans wind up quitting and
eating meat well if they've ever done a
study on that this is like a big thing
as you know there's been a movement as
sort of a movement and people have
different success rates with being a
vegan but Cam Newton who is a
quarterback of the Carolina Panthers big
dude
six six 250 260 he went vegan and he
cannot get healthy he cannot he's been
injured he's I mean the face of the
franchise
probably a hundred million dollar
contract I mean made it to the Super
Bowl but since just been on a decline
and it's like almost hand-in-hand with
the change into vegan well you know that
guy dr. Sean
Baker he's yeah yeah marks all these
people that were in originally in that
game-changers documentary that James
Cameron put out yeah a [ __ ] ton of them
quit before the movie came out and they
had to pull him out of the movie because
they were vegan and because of health
reasons they had to quit
it's an indoctrination movie and it's
also it's extremely biased and it's not
focusing on all of the various problems
that people have it's only focused on
the positive aspects of it and
distorting the reality of those positive
messages particularly the strong man
who's on a fuckload of steroids
yeah they forget that they forget that
part yeah and then all these other
athletes like these you're not talking
and even the strongmen he's not like a
elite strongman you're not talking about
some like when I had Robert Oberst in
here right he's like everybody eats the
same [ __ ] he's like meat and rice like
they meet yeah all those strong men eat
the same thing the real strong men the
ones who actually win the competitions
what do you got Jamie it's a very
controversial research and it came out
but it's a very repeated number of 84
percent of vegans and vegetarians end up
going back to eating meat of at some
level yeah right right before they die
folks we're omnivores we're omnivores we
we exist better we are more healthy on
an animal and vegetable diet yeah and if
you don't want to kill animals please
eat eggs eat oysters eat shrimp and
lobsters they're [ __ ] heartless sold
us little monsters that live at the
bottom of the ocean right but if you
want to be healthy just eating only
vegetables is a [ __ ] hard road it's a
hard road and this idea that you're
gonna save the world
listen large scare at large-scale
agriculture is [ __ ] terrible for the
environment it's terrible you want it
like they all of our agricultural lands
when they talk about greenhouse gases we
talked about this the other day 9% of
all of all greenhouse gases is because
of agriculture less than half of that is
because of meat less than half of that
is because of beef elk yeah how much is
that oh man it's [ __ ] zero yeah you
have weight if you just eat out you have
way less impact on the greenhouse gases
than you do if you're a vegetarian and
that's a fact right if you're eating
grain not
you're eating green man you're
responsible for a fuckload of death
whether you like it or not sure those
mattress combines yeah rapid
discriminate deer fawns mice
forget about inserts yeah and then the
pesticides displacement of wildlife
you're not supposed to have enormous
fields filled with [ __ ] corn right
and grain wheat and all that [ __ ] that's
not normal yeah it's not I think there's
definitely animals dying from that which
I you know but for us to live animals
are gonna die you know no matter how you
want to look at it at some point whether
it was to build your house or build the
road you used to get to work or if or
the fields that you eat your your salad
and corn and and wheat from animals
dying for us to live that's just that
that's just how it works you cannot live
on this earth and not have animals die
because of that and I like that these
people that are vegans are doing this
and they think this way because they
care because they don't want suffering
they want these animals to live hmm look
I don't want factory farming I think
it's terrible it doesn't none of that
appeals to me at all when I see chickens
stuffed into cages like that I don't
have anything to do with that I don't
want to I want to boycott every step of
the way when I see pigs stuffed into
those cages too next to each other
sitting on the floor I don't want to
have any part of that I want to boycott
all of that with same thing with beef
same thing with anything that's factory
farm yeah but that's not what we're
doing no no and I there are some good
cattle ranchers that have good
operations it's not the factory farm
they're doing it right and it's like
more people are more in tune with that
like one of my son's works at a Tami
shop at a grocery store and he said
people ask all the time where's this
meat from how was it raised so people
are getting yes and it's like supporting
ethical cattle ranching I'm all for that
me too that's awesome that's one of the
great things about one of my sponsors is
butcher box and butcher box has a total
commitment to humanely raised animals
100% grass-fed grass-finished beef no
antibiotics no hormones ever so they
have these relationships with cattle
ranchers and they use sustainable ranch
sustainable farming so when you're
buying meat from a good source like that
you're cutting out all the stuff that I
hate about about farming well about
factory farming me too
yeah they're good outfit
[Applause]